Democrats impeach President Trump in the
house historic day the media journalism
all over themselves and President Trump
rallies the base I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show this show is
sponsored by expressvpn stop putting
your online data at risk get protected
at expressvpn dot-com slash Penn well
Mary impeachment is those that the
Washington Post's say each and every day
Mary impeachments to you Mary impeach
miss I guess is how they're putting it
it is very exciting news
the New York Times splashing across its
front page Trump a beached and then the
Washington Post Trump impeached
everybody very excited about the
impeachment the Washington Post reveled
in this Philip Rucker falesha San mez
and Kobe it quits the House of
Representatives voted late Wednesday to
impeach President Trump on charges that
he abused his office and obstructed
Congress with Democrats declaring him a
threat to the nation and branding an
indelible mark on most turbulent
presidency of modern times Oh an
indelible mark is it so indelible
because when people think of Bill
Clinton's presidency the only thing they
think about his impeachment not the
economy now welfare reform not the fact
that his wife would go on and become a
democratic nominee herself nope they
only think about the impeachment it's an
indelible mark after 11 hours of fierce
arguments on the House floor between
Democrats and Republicans over Trump's
conduct with Ukraine lawmakers voted so
voted almost entirely along party lines
to impeach him by the way the only
people who did not vote along party
lines were the two three Democrats who
voted not to impeach and Tulsi Gabbard
who abstained from the voting who voted
present Trump becomes the third
president in US history to face travel
in the Senate a proceeding that will
determine whether he's removed from
office less than one year before he
stands for reelection spoiler alert nope
not gonna happen according to the
Washington Post on Trump's 1060 second
day in office Congress brought a
momentous reckoning momentous reckoning
to an unorthodox president who has
tested America's institutions with an
array of unrestrained actions including
some that a collection of his own
appointees and other government
witnesses testified or reckless an
endangered national security
it's a reckoning momentous momentous
reckoning and he saw Democrats cheering
yesterday I'm very very excited about
all of this
then there was that awkward moment where
they realize he's not exiting office and
you got that that
Jif of kanye west or he's smiling and
then it suddenly does he went that
that's kind of the democrats as they
realized that the impeachment doesn't
mean anything because it's an entirely
political act and they do not run the
senate the Democratic controlled house
passed two articles of impeachment
against Trump abuse of power and
obstruction of Congress neither of which
is a crime of course the House voted 232
197 to approve the article charging
abuse of power with the gavel falling
about 8:30 p.m. right in the middle of
the masked singer so you had this
bizarre split screen on Fox they cut
they cut into the masked singer to show
the commentators on Fox News and
everybody's like wait a second I want to
know that who the Fox was like why
doesn't someone just tell me who the Fox
was no one cares about the impeachment
let's be real about this
I'm the obstruction of Congress vote
which followed soon after the tally was
229 to 198 all Republicans voted against
both articles among Democrats to voted
no on the first article three voted no
on the second representative Tulsi
Gabbard voted present both times House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi framed the day's
proceedings so here was Nancy Pelosi's
opening statement was very solemn very
somber and this was the supposed mood
that was being created salamis some
Burness solemnity sadness and any other
s word you can think of that makes you
feel very sober here is Nancy Pelosi
wearing her emperor palpatine costume
and then reciting the Pledge of
Allegiance which again the last time I
checked Democrats wanted to ban from
public school classrooms but here's
Nancy Pelosi very sadly now our founders
vision of a republic is under threat
from actions from the White House that
is why today a Speaker of the House I
solemnly and sadly opened the debate on
the impeachment of the President of the
United States if we do not act now we
would be derelict in our duty it is
tragic that the president's reckless
actions make impeachment necessary
he gave us no choice no you had a choice
and you just didn't do it now the best
part again of all this was the
theatrical stupidity of all this the
Democrats pretending that they're very
solemn and upset about having to do this
despite the fact that again they've
spent three years openly screaming for
lightning to hit
openly praying that the alligator moat
opens up beneath Trump the Jabba the
Hutt's gate opens up and Trump falls
down into the rancor pepper I mean
that's what they've been praying for for
three long years and finally they did it
yesterday and they're like no it's we're
not excited about this we're not excited
about this yeah you you're not excited
about this mm-hmm
yours about you're about is not excited
about this as a new husband on his
wedding night
let sure sure here's here's a montage of
all the Democrats proclaiming how sad
and solemn and solemn and sad and
Solomon's head and sober they are today
under the dome of this temple of
democracy to exercise one of the most
solemn powers that this body can take
it's with solemn purpose today that I
vote to impede madam Speaker it is with
a song sense of duty that I write madam
Speaker as we take this solemn necessary
step of impeaching President Trump rise
in this solemn occasion impeaching the
president is one of the most solemn and
consequential I cast the sound vote for
the many individuals in my district
members of Congress swear a solemn oath
to protect and defend the Constitution
against all enemies foreign and domestic
and today we fulfill our oath madam
Speaker I rise with a heavy heart to
support this resolution I rise today
with a heavy heart it is with a heavy
heart but I resolved one madam Speaker
it is with a heavy heart and a profound
sense of the gravity of this moment that
I rise today in support of the
impeachment madam Speaker I rise with a
heavy heart the two most difficult votes
any member of Congress ever asked to
cast a vote to go to war or to impeach
today a Speaker of the House I soundly
and sadly opened the debate this is a
very sad day and I do not take
impeachment likely I'm saddened but I'm
not shocked it's with profound sadness
that I stand here today and it is a sad
day in America today sadly we are voting
to impeach president Donald John Trump
yes I am saddened but I'm not sure
everybody said everybody said so sad now
if you believe this it's because
unbelievably stupid and gullible so sad
oh you can see them ripping tears but
it's so upset and they're so sober it's
like a funeral out there I mean it's a
so sober what a sober moment in
America's history when we have to
impeach this guy that we absolutely wish
would just effing die like man if it's
it's just wow it's so sober and so sad
and so sober sad here looking it by the
way we're gonna show how this out was
not true in just one second first let us
talk about the fact that it can be very
difficult to find the right part for
your for your car now if you aren't car
illiterate the way that I am
this means that very often when your car
breaks down you drive to some sort of
auto body shop and then the next thing
you know somebody is selling you a part
that is too expensive this has happened
to me or you go on over to one of the
big box stores and you buy the part and
you come on home your dad drives you and
you come on home with the part you open
up your car you go to put um it in and
you realize that it is the wrong part
you have now wasted an hour and a half
and you have to go back and replace it
and then you do it wrong again yes that
happened to me instead why don't you
just go to Rock Auto calm Rock Auto calm
is a family business serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers they've got
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps motor oil
even new carpet whether it's for your
classic or daily driver you can get
everything you need and a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
the rockauto.com catalog is incredibly
easy to navigate you can quickly see all
the parts available for your vehicle and
filter by brands specifications and
prices I'm not a car guy and that makes
Rock Auto calm even better because it
means that I don't really have to worry
about going to the store and getting the
wrong thing
best of all prices at Rock Auto dot-com
are always reliably low and safe and the
same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers it's a great site for
car enthusiasts as well they've got
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
Rock Auto Congo - Rock auto calm right
now see all the parts available for your
car or truck right Shapiro's in there
how did you hear about us box so they
know we sent you again go check them out
at Rock Auto dot-com Nancy Pelosi she
actually had to glare at her own
Democrats so CNN and reported earlier in
the day that Nancy Pelosi had told all
of the Democrats to be extremely sober
very sober and sad and so they went up
there and they did this routine that has
said they
but how this is just it's a
constitutional duty it's not that we
hope that President Trump spontaneously
combusts like a Charles Dickens
character we it really is mainly that we
just we love the Constitution so much so
yesterday she announces the vote on
impeachment and people start cheering
and Nancy Pelosi has to turn to them and
and shake them off just it turns to them
and try it no guys don't do that don't
do that you're giving away the game
don't you see I'm wearing my black sober
and somber and sad I'm wearing my
funeral suit today
you don't cheer at a funeral here's
Nancy Pelosi announcing the impeachment
and then if you could see this is why I
should subscribe you can see her
actually shake off the members of her
own party who are openly celebrating the
confetti is coming down and we plan
their plan we are the champions the
whole deal and that's Melissa Shh
article one is adopted
[Applause]
people start laughing in the chamber
because it's ridiculous she's trying to
pretend that they're so sober and that
face man that face how'd you like to see
that face coming at you sir great you're
the grandchild and you took some cookies
from the top shelf and you got that face
coming at you oh my goodness that is not
a great look okay so the Democrats very
solemn and sober now how do they
actually feel about this
leave it to Rasheeda to leave who said
that she wanted to impeach the mother
effer
to express how Democrats truly felt and
shoes on her way to the House floor to
vote on impeachment and the same crazy
lady who went to a trump rally and was
thrown out for screaming at President
Trump the same rabid anti-semite who was
so crazily anti-semitic she voted down a
democratic anti-israel proposition
because it was too pro-israel Rasheeda
Talib was walking to the floor and she's
smiling and laughing she could not be
happier this is the best day since
presumably something bad happened to a
Jew somewhere here's Rasheeda Talib I
mean she is so excited she's so pumped
man woo but also somber and sad and
sober and satins humber here she is hey
everyone I am on my way to the United
States House floor to impeach President
Trump on behalf of my incredible
district 13 districts Ron okay she is
not actually winning an Oscar she's just
on her way to vote for an impeachment
resolution that doesn't actually contain
a crime so clearly the Democrats were
very upset about this so upset and we
know that they're really serious because
they are so president sad and somber
serious super sad and somber I mean we
know this we know this hey then they get
up there and they say just a bunch of
crazy things a bunch of crazy things
about how if Trump isn't impeached it's
the end of the Republic so yesterday
they go on for hours this way everybody
got like one minute to speak and in that
minute it was sort of a game of
one-upsmanship on the Democratic side
the game was how bad can we say Trump is
and on the Republican side the game was
how badly can we say the Trump is being
treated and so we got these parallel
acts of stupidity we're Democrats on the
one hand were saying if President Trump
is not impeached he will declare the
absolute power he will he will order
executive order 66 and take over the
galaxy
to murder all the Jedi younglings if he
takes if we don't impeach him on the one
hand and then on the other hand you have
the Republicans being like this man this
Donald J Trump this man has been treated
worse than Jesus Christ this man right
here
this man has been treated worse than any
human being who has ever been treated on
the face of the earth yeah we've had a
few who were shot in office but aside
from that he has been treated like worse
than Lincoln worse than worse than
anyone and so we have these two parallel
conversations because everything is
incredibly stupid and this is a complete
waste of time we'll get to more of that
in just one second first let's talk
about cryptocurrency for a second so you
hear a crypto new that means secret and
that probably means that no
cryptocurrency is is basically a digital
form of currency that is not manipulable
web by central governments one of the
great threats to your savings is the
central government blowing up the
spending and then blowing up the
inflation rate in order to pay off that
spending and that will happen sooner or
later in the United States it's one of
the reasons why so many people are
interested in trading and
cryptocurrencies because once you have
enough people trading a cryptocurrency
which is protected by blockchain it
can't be inflated and so it effectively
is a form of digital hard assets like a
digital gold so that the idea is that if
you invest in those sorts of currencies
then at least the government can't
manipulate you well this is what
cryptocurrency does and this is why
maybe you should explore investing in
cryptocurrency George Gilder The
Economist has talked about this if
you're interested in getting into the
cryptocurrency markets but you actually
don't know much why don't you check out
eToro
you can check out copy trader by eToro
copy trader allows you to automatically
copy every trade of e toros top crypto
traders at the exact price in real time
that's pretty cool cuz if you don't know
anything you can just crib off somebody
else's cheat sheet eToro social trading
platform has over 11 million traders
facilitates over 1 trillion dollars in
trading volume per year globally you can
access the world's best crypto currency
sign up today at eToro comm slash
shapiro that's ETO ro comm slash shapiro
eToro dot-com slash Schapiro go check
them out right now again crypto it's an
interesting way to diversify your
portfolio and it also allows you to keep
your assets
affected from central governments which
is an important thing check them out at
eToro comm slash of hero ET oro comm
shapiro okay so we begin with the
democrats and their overall case so
representative jaya paul who is sort of
an adjunct member of the squad she's not
really a member of the squad but she's
sort of like the fifth Beatle who really
wants to make it into the squad and is
never lenin
so she explains yesterday that if we do
not impeach trump then we will live in a
monarchy or a dictatorship in which case
i suppose that baron does become an
actual baron and eventually becomes
president of the united states which is
exciting and odd here is representative
jaya Paul from Washington without that
we are no longer a democracy we are a
monarchy or a dictatorship and so today
to uphold my oath to Constitution and
country I will vote to impeach Donald J
Trump wow just wow she's what it what a
hero what a hero jan Schakowsky from
illinois she let the cat out of the bag
because she's radical and crazy also
that's a that's a wild Konica pen i mean
like as an Orthodox Jew I gotta say that
that is that is pretty hideous but in
any case doing a big Hanukah pin on her
on her right side she says my son
convinced me to impeach well before
Ukraine well isn't that sort of
undercutting your argument of serious
sober somber and sadness here is
representative Jay Paul in a
representative Schakowsky in the holiday
spirit
it is my adult son I in Schakowsky whom
I will always credit from my decision
last June to support an impeachment
inquiry it had never been my goal to
impeach a president but I in made such a
compelling case he reminded me of the
oath I have taken eleven times now to
support and defend the Constitution of
the United States he said mom this is
not about politics this is not about
party oh it isn't but also I was
interested in doing this well before
Ukraine
Jackie Speier came out of the woodwork
from California her her last brilliant
stratagem was that Mitch McConnell
should recuse himself in the Senate
because Mitch McConnell is going to vote
to acquit and obviously campy an
impartial juror
the process is not about impartiality as
the entirely partisan vote yesterday
shows in any case representative spire
goes all the way to Hitler if we don't
do anything here then Hitler take over
here's jackie speier explaining that
president Trump is cut like when her
parents escaped Hitler they didn't mean
to come to a country where Hitler could
rise again here's jackie speier my
father fled Nazi Germany for America
because he saw what happened when a
despot became untethered he fled because
he believed in democracy in the rule of
law and the right to vote and today
today all of those are in danger because
of orange the White House he's going to
come jackie spires house and he's going
to force her to receive a tax cut very
serious people very very serious people
and then you get Al Green right Al Green
not the singer the Congress person Al
Green who has been for years suggesting
the president Trump should be impeached
he gets up there with a giant poster
that says impeach now now does that have
a picture of like a suffering soldier in
Ukraine or something like something
connected or doesn't have a picture of
sad face Joe Biden no it has a picture
of the crying child you remember from
the immigration debate there's only one
problem with that crying child story the
crying child was not actually separated
from her mom right so that that that's
that picture is not even like real okay
it's like it's a real picture of a
person crying but it is not in fact an
example of president Trump's evil
brutality The Washington Post reported
all the way back in June 2018 that that
that the girl's father told The
Washington Post his child and her mother
were not even separated according to
Border Patrol
so Al Green busts out this picture right
of this little girl crying and he's
using that photo and um and then what
does that have to do with Ukraine like I
get it you just won't like Trump right I
mean that that's basically what you're
saying here and then you got Hakeem
Jeffries Hakeem Jeffries from New York
he suggests you know what people keep
saying that this impeachment thing is
divisive that's not divisive you know it
was divisive slavery slavery was
divisive which is like one of my
favourite old jokes when my favorite old
jokes is what's worse than finding a
worm in your Apple finding half a worm
in your Apple what's worse than finding
half a worm in your Apple stage for
cancer
well yes it is true this is not as
divisive as slavery you're correct it's
not as divisive points to you Hakeem
Jeffries I'm pretty sure that doesn't
mean it's not divisive but like yeah if
we're gonna go to yeah like you're
having a fight but I can't imagine
breaking this out in a fight with my
wife she's like God you're just being
terrible really
am I being as terrible as the people who
enslaved people that's kind of a non
sequitur Harris Hakeem Jeffries they're
dropping farside ask Gary Larson
non-sequiturs there are some who
cynically argue that the impeachment of
this president will further divide an
already fractured Union but there is a
difference between division and
clarification slavery once divided the
nation but emancipator's rose up to
clarify that all men are created equally
um okay
meanwhile Tulsi gabbard's saying the
only thing that is true and Tulsi
Gabbard who may run as an independent by
the way she released a statement on the
impeachment of President Trump and she
said that this is a partisan effort and
so I'm voting present she said I'm
standing in the center I've decided to
vote present I could not in good
conscience vote against impeachment
because I believe President Trump is
guilty of wrongdoing I also could not in
good conscience vote for impeachment
because removal of a sitting president
must not be the culmination of a
partisan process fueled by tribal
animosities that have so gravely divided
our country when I cast my vote in
support of the impeachment inquiry
nearly three months ago I said that in
order to maintain the integrity of this
solemn undertaking it must not be a
partisan endeavor
tragically that's what it has been on
the one side the president's defenders
insist that he has done nothing wrong
they agree with the absurd proclamation
that his conduct was perfect they've
abdicated their responsibility to
exercise legitimate oversight and
instead blindly do the bidding of their
party's leader on the other side the
president's opponents insist that if we
do not impeach our country will collapse
instant dictatorship all but explicitly
they accuse him of treason
such extreme rhetoric was never
conducive to an impartial fact-finding
process how have you all made me into a
Tulsi Gabbard fan how how I mean that
she's
only reasonable person in the house
apparently and meanwhile on the
Republican side of the aisle Kevin
McCarthy the the House Minority Leader
he said something that is true he got
all sorts of flat floored he said this
is obviously an attempt to appease the
Democrat partisan socialistic base which
is which is true Nancy Pelosi who it's
funny she was being praised yesterday
for her iron control of the house the
fact is that she hadn't lost control of
the house back in March to Ilhan Omar
then none of this would have happened if
she had not lost control to the radicals
in her party she wouldn't move forward
with this thing she lost control she
tried to reassert control by pushing for
impeachment she thought there would be
more there than there was there wasn't
enough there and she pushed forward
anywhere here's McCarthy it didn't have
to be this way is this why we came here
to serve to trample on due process
rights to issue more subpoenas than laws
to appease the new Democrat socialist
base
mm every spooling no he's right he's
right okay but and then there were the
Republicans who were wrong so
Representative Mike Kelly gets up there
from Pennsylvania and he says this is
like Pearl Harbor not so much you know
like when the Japanese Imperial forces
attacked America at Hawaii and killed a
thousand Americans more than a thousand
Americans like not not so much like that
I mean like if I were gonna go with like
things that it's like that's not on the
list here he is saying a thing on
December 7th 1941 a horrific act
happened in the United States and this
one that President Roosevelt said this
is a date that will live in infamy today
December the 18th 2019 is another date
that will live in infamy when just
because you hate the President of the
United States and you can find no other
reason other than the fact that you're
so blinded by your hate that you can't
see straight that you've decided the
only way we can make sure this president
doesn't get elected again is to impeach
him yeah um it's not really like Pearl
Harbor and like at all and then the
worst one was was representing Barry
Loudermilk from Georgia he gets up and
he says president Trump is being treated
worse than Jesus well seeing as Jesus
was actually crucified and died on the
cross if you're a Christian for his sins
was resurrected if you're a Jew just
died on the cross no matter how you
slice it wasn't particularly great for
Jesus that trial was not I would say
like a real great example of due process
I'm gonna go with no on the Trump to
Jesus comparison on this one before you
take this historic vote today one week
before Christmas I want you to keep this
in mind when Jesus was falsely accused
of treason Pontius Pilate gave Jesus the
opportunity to face his accusers during
that sham trial Pontius Pilate afforded
more rights to Jesus than the Democrats
have afforded this president in this
process merry Christmas to you
whoa nope that's a no on that so things
that just for the record things that
this impeachment is not like the Salem
witch trials the crucifixion
of Jesus Pearl Harbor things the
impeachment is like an impeachment just
gonna put that out there I feel like
that's the safe thing to say okay in a
second we're gonna get to president
Trump's response to all of this because
President Trump went off you went off
and then we will get to Nancy Pelosi's
latest stratagem Wow the master
strategist at work
that's it Pelosi we'll get to that in
like so stupid sorry it's idiotic it's a
in one idiotic second first let's talk
about the fact that if you are running a
business you need to make sure that you
have all the numbers in front of you
like we have here at daily wear an
entire finance and accounting department
designed to track all the numbers and we
have an integrated system one of the
reasons we have an integrated system is
because we have been using NetSuite and
you should use that suite also because
if you're using a variety of systems
like you're an old-fashioned company and
you got one person using excel and
you've got another person who is using
the mac books and you have just people
using various different applications
various different ways of keeping track
of your finances you're not getting the
full picture of your business well this
is why you need an integrated business
solution and this is where NetSuite
comes in if you don't know your numbers
you don't know your business but a lot
of growing businesses have that
hodgepodge of business systems now you
need NetSuite by Oracle it's the
business management software that
handles every aspect of your business in
an easy-to-use cloud platform getting
you the visibility and control you need
to grow with NetSuite you save time
money unneeded headaches by managing
sales finance and accounting orders HR
instantly right from your desktop or
phone managing a business without
understanding every aspect of your
business it's a fool's errand it makes
your business less efficient pledge to
make your business more efficient in the
new year go to NetSuite right now right
now NetSuite is offering you valuable
insights with a free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite comm slash Shapiro that is
NetSuite comm slash Shapiro to download
your free guide seven key strategies to
grow your profits
NetSuite comm slash Shapiro that is
NEETs you ite NetSuite comm slash
Shapiro go check them out
right now okay so president Trump
responds to all of this hubbub yesterday
he has a tweet on the impeachment and
this is actually correct okay this is
actually correct it's a picture of
President Trump in black and white
staring at the camera man style and it
says in reality they're not after me
that after you I'm just in the way that
how most conservatives feel this is what
I've been pointing out over the last
several days saying about Ukraine it
ain't about what Trump did or what he
didn't do but this is really about for
most Americans is the media and the
Democrats targeting Trump because they
hate that Trump is president and they
hate that a lot of people voted for him
and I think that that's what the polls
are showing can the polls have cut
against this impeachment the Democrats
did not prove a bipartisan case they did
not even prove criminal conduct instead
they just threw something against the
wall they threw the poop against the
wall it didn't quite stick and now
they're mad about it so president
Trump's is this huge rally in Michigan
last night he got up on stage as soon as
they started the vocals it was obvious
that this whole thing was was going to
go in favor of impeachment that wasn't
going to be stopped
Mike Pence began the rally he introduced
the rally by saying this thing is a
complete disgrace so here is the Vice
President of the United States saying
that this thing is a disgrace you know
what's going on in Washington DC tonight
is a disgrace
from day one of this administration
Democrats in Washington have been trying
to overturn the results of the last
election and they're back at it tonight
with this partisan impeachment vote
you know the truth is men and women
they're trying to impeach this president
because they know they can't defeat this
president yeah and there is truth to all
this president from for his part he was
jazzed up about this here's the thing
Trump thrives on the conflicts he kind
of likes the conflict so President Trump
gets up this is his favorite place to be
under fire in front of a big crowd of
supporters that is his place I mean that
is his comfort place some of us have a
quiet room where we sip coffee and think
about our lives president from has giant
rallies filled with supporters where he
yells about how how he's being smacked
around and how he's gonna take those
hits he loves this so here as President
Trump in the mood in the mood Rommel he
says it doesn't feel like we're being
impeached because the reality is most
Americans don't care about it and he's
correct about this it doesn't really
feel like we're being impeached than
ever before we did nothing wrong
did nothing wrong
and we have tremendous support in the
Republican Party like we've never had
before okay and then he goes on and he
says listen Democrats right here they're
not to clearing their hatred for me
they're declaring their hatred for the
American voter with today's illegal
unconstitutional and partisan
impeachment they do not think Democrats
and they are do nothing all they want to
do is focus on this what they could be
doing argit blaring their deep hatred
and disdain for the american voter again
he is correct about this when he says
that this is really about the democrats
can't accept what happened in the last
election correct and then he goes on he
says Democrats have branded themselves
with the mark of shame okay if you like
theatrics this is your sort of thing if
you feel like it's a little bit
overwrought then that like on all sides
then I guess you're kind of bored but if
you love the man the circus is in town
and let's do this thing through their
depraved actions today crazy Nancy
Pelosi's House Democrats branded
themselves with an eternal mark of shame
in it it really is it's a disgrace okay
all of this is fine
then President Trump gets a rollin and
he gets a rollin and once blue toes are
rolling don't stop him so he starts with
the insults the insult comedy so there's
another one of president from favorite
things to do so he starts off by going
after crooked Hillary you know you go
with the old crowd pleasers the old
favorites he says bill is walking around
the house calling for crooked Hillary so
what happens is Bill Clinton said to
crooked Hillary his very dishonest wife
said crooked Hillary do you think he
calls her crooked Hillary my
maybe he just calls her cooking
he said crooked I'm telling you okay so
that's funny okay and then he goes after
Adam Schiff again now he's already
called him pencil-neck then he starts
talking about how Adam Schiff is ugly so
we basically got triumph the insult
comic dog doing a presidential address
[Music]
America here's President Trump gone
after Adam Schiff and call him and ugly
Mike yeah just like Lincoln would just
like Lincoln no he's a corrupt but and
then I see him by the way you ever see
this guy he walks up to the mugs I mean
we're not in or ferret look I don't want
to be cuz with me too I never even think
about looks anymore okay I don't talk
about looks of a male or female but in
his case let's just say last time I'll
ever refer to this he's not exactly the
best-looking guy without us
oh it's so stupid
everything is stupid the impeachment is
stupid the response to the impeachment
is stupid the speech is stupid
everything's stupid if you can't enjoy
this I don't know it's wrong with you
like at least you got to enjoy the ride
man
again we all bought this ticket we all
have a part to play here we'll get two
presidents a president from starts with
the insult comedy and he starts here and
it's like it's pretty good and then he's
sort of like looking into a little dicey
ER territory and then President Trump is
like they're still laughing they're
still laughing watch me throughout a
full-on Richard Pryor and then he just
goes for it we'll talk to you let's talk
about president from going for it and
why him having no lines is like the
biggest obstacle to his own reelection
is Trump right obviously and then we'll
get to the Democratic strategy on
impeachment moving forward which is one
of the Dumber strategies I have ever
heard in my entire life we'll get to
that in just one second first
hye-rin can be a challenge not just for
those of us here at the Daily wire also
for codable founder Gretchen nur
rut you needed to hire a game artist for
her education tech company
she knew it wouldn't be easy to find
someone to grow with her team and that's
why she headed over to zip recruiter zip
recruiter doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it finds them for you it's
technology identifies people with the
right experience invites them to apply
to your job so you get qualified
candidates fast
Gretchen posted her job on zip recruiter
she said she was impressed with how
quickly she found qualified applicants
she also used zip recruiters screening
questions to filter candidates so she
could focus on the best ones and that's
how Gretchen found a new game artist in
less than two weeks with results like
that it's no wonder four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the very
first day finding the right employees
can make your company so much better
like say that you had a producer and
that producer had risen all the way
through the ranks of your company I mean
just really a stellar employee and say
that he had made just one mistake in his
life and that was that he had not
proposed to his longtime girlfriend and
you were just on the verge of thinking
to yourself this guy has bad judgment we
have to get rid of this guy but then he
made the proposal well then you wouldn't
have to use zip recruit but if you do
need to replace somebody if you do need
to replace somebody or you need to get a
new employee who's fantastic zip
recruiter com is the way to do it see
you why zip recruit is effective for
businesses of all sizes try
zip recruiter for free at our web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that is zip recruiter comm slash
Dai ly WI re
zip recruiter comm daily wire zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire and
by the way congratulations to Mathis and
Caitlyn who got engaged yesterday for
those of you who are longtime followers
of the show those names have cropped up
before math was like the very first
producer on this show and he is now one
of the heads of production and he just
proposed to Caitlyn who also works and
Rob is like amazing news I'm very happy
about that also good news for you we
have the perfect gift for you to give
this holiday season the gift of a daily
wire membership from now until January
1st all insider plus gift memberships
will be 25% off that means your loved
one will get all the fantastic perks
plus the majestic leftist ears tumblr
and you will receive the savings if
you're not already a subscriber you are
really missing out head on over to daily
wire comm and subscribe again that's 25%
off all inside our plus gift memberships
this holiday season give them a gift
they will thank you for all year long go
to daily wire.com slash gift to get your
25% off again
that's daily wire comm slash gift get
your 25% off do not wait
stop depriving yourself come join the
fun also one of the reasons why you
should absolutely subscribe is because
you get awesome Sunday specials on
Saturday this sunday special has on kirk
cameron the heartthrob for every woman
who is over the age of like 25 and Mike
Seaver Mike Seaver stopped by and he's
become a marriage and family advocate
he's a deep deeply believing Christian
really a fascinating guy a really great
dude here's a little bit of what that
sounded like by the time I graduated
high school doors were opening for an
acting career and I thought I might as
well keep this this career going and the
doors that were opening were lining up
with what was happening to me on the
inside I want to be about things that
promote faith I want to be about things
that promote family and marriage and
Here I am looking in the rearview mirror
saying this has been awesome it's pretty
spectacular I mean this is somebody who
really gave up some fame and fortune to
lead a more fulfilling life Couric has
like he has six kids four of them
adopted what an amazing dude go check
that out
there's Sundays special it comes out on
Saturday if you are a subscriber you
should subscribe anyway and again you
get the 25 percent off all the way in
first together the largest fastest
scoring conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
you
so president Trump's response to the
impeachment is pretty much right on it's
like look this is just partisan they're
after you they're not really after me
and that is true but president Trump's
just reminded us last night that his
greatest asset is the fact that the
media hate him and in fact the Democrats
hate him and his greatest fable is the
fact that he cannot stop himself so he
starts with the insult comedy at his
rally in Michigan and he starts off with
the crooked Hillary bit which is very
funny and then he goes on to the Adam
Schiff bit which is a little bit less
funny but still kind of funny and then
he goes after John Dingle John Dingle so
double Dingle is a representative in
Michigan she just took over her husband
John Dingle see John Dingle was in
Congress for 1,000 years and he recently
died and Trump in the middle of this
rally sort of dumps out the idea that
John Dingle may be in Hell which is like
oh my god here's the president do this
do that do that Rotunda everything I
gave him everything that's okay I don't
want anything for I don't need anything
for anything she calls me up it's the
nicest thing that's ever happened thank
you so much John would be so thrilled
he's looking down he'd be something
thank you so much sir I said that's okay
don't worry about it
maybe he's looking up I don't know okay
so Debbie Dingell then went on national
TV and she's like um you probably
shouldn't imply that my husband's in
hell that seems like a not a good thing
to do and um correct
fact-check true you probably shouldn't
do that here is Debbie Dingell you know
I think it's time to put politics aside
on these kind of shots I try to be
respectful of everybody I've never taken
a personal shot at this president I
think his family is off limits I was
very grateful by the way he I didn't
call him he called me to tell me he was
lowering the flags and that meant a lot
I don't want to politicize my husband I
don't want to politicize his death it is
still something that I'm really grieving
over this Thanksgiving was really hard
and Christmas is harder and I'm gonna go
back to doing my job and doing a good
job for the people of my district okay
so again the greatest threat to Trump's
reelection is is not the Democrats it's
not the media it's Trump doing this kind
of stuff okay speaking of the media the
media yesterday just I mean they put on
they're somber sad serious sober faces
and they went right along with Nancy
Pelosi yeah Dana Bash over at CNN going
this was very serious and very great you
could feel the gravity on the floor so
many sad yes I'm sure they were
heartbroken just like the members of the
media who are going out back popping
champagne is will show you in a moment
you can feel it in the air here it feels
different it is palpable that this is
momentous that this is brave and again
it is
despite the Democrats talking points not
something that this speaker wanted to do
for and about this president they
definitely didn't want to do it guys
they do by the way Nancy Pelosi said
everybody has a spring in their step
this morning so yeah they sorted it Wolf
Blitzer did the same thing it's a sober
moment on Capitol Hill says wolf in any
minute we expect I think there are about
234 House Democrats they have the
majority now since the 2018 election in
any moment we expect many if not most or
even all potentially of them to come to
the floor of the House of
Representatives and stand with speaker
Pelosi as they begin this procedure this
very serious rebuke of President Trump
the impeachment only the third time in
American history it's happened it's a
somber somber mood up on Capitol Hill
such a somber mood supremely somber so
somber here's Nancy Pelosi this morning
saying also we have a spring in our step
we're and now she's wearing again she's
you can chart her mood by the by the
wardrobe I like that it's sort of like
kid in movies when they cast movies and
women when they decided to wardrobe for
movies they tend to have the garments
reflect the interior mood of the person
so if you watch the star I've made a
bunch of Star Wars references it's on my
mind my kids are into it right now if
you watch Emperor Palpatine when he
Senator Palpatine he wears blues and
reds and then s/he becomes Emperor
Palpatine he wears black
so yesterday she was in her Emperor
Palpatine mu now she is in her Senator
Palpatine mood and she says no listen
I'm happy today today I'm a happy really
what happened is sad somber sober Sirius
Nancy what happened to her here she is
now she's got a spring in her step and
she's got some she's got a smile and
okay here she is we've been hearing from
people all over the country and the last
since last night and this morning seems
like people have a spring in their step
because the president was held
accountable for his reckless behavior no
one is above the law and the
Constitution is the supreme law of the
land no one is above the law and the
president has been held accountable
she looks so upset and so sad I mean
like she's gonna cry right there also
she she started then hobbling away going
when there's a shine on your shoes
there's a melody in your heart what a
singable happy feelin wonderful way to
start when there's like full Fred
Astaire routine from the bandwagon it
was really weird
but she did it anyway The Washington
Post reporters were also extremely
excited so the Washington Post reporters
they went out drinking here was their
picture did they look
somber sober sad serious Rachel bade
who's one of the reporters she tweeted
out Miriam beech myths from the
Washington Post team pique capital is
buying and this is and then she had to
delete it she's like I didn't really
mean that we're pro-impeachment oh yes
he looks super Sobers had somber serious
I remember when you took this picture
like last week in the middle of the
impeachment hearings and then you no no
and then she's like we didn't mean this
to be biased oh oh didn't you
Oh didn't you now my and then you've got
Chris Matthews so the Democrats have set
up this conundrum
if Trump stays in office he's gonna
steal the next election if he leaves
office and he won't steal the next
election but we don't actually have the
grounds to oust him to have Chris
Matthews who's out there doing the
full-on Democrat routine will end over
here no matter they show come in there
now that trumps me impeach he's gonna do
anything to stay in office he'll just do
anything as opposed to before and he
would do anything to stay in office no
he's definitely gonna do anything to
stay in office it's as though I had a
conclusion already written in my head
and then I just kind of rode in your old
grumper and I was like let's just say it
again huh go here's now ugly because he
used to word you today impeachment is
ugly I'm now ugly how is he going to
react to this he's now ugly in history
is ugly in history and how is he gonna
react to that is he you know is he gonna
break worse but I'll tell you one thing
that's gonna do to him he now will do
anything to get reelected because it's
the only way back for him is to is to
double this to win twice no matter what
the deep state
make media here we go etc he has to win
the next time he's ugly in history
I mean look super ugly super it's gonna
break bad he's gonna start cooking meth
is that what's gonna happen we're gonna
have Trump meth with big che won't we go
there won't be boobie god ha Chris
Matthews and so what exactly is Nancy
Pelosi going to do now so here's the
problem for the Democrats yesterday was
a big day for them like yeah we impeach
the president now he's definitely not
gonna be the oh wait like now Oh like
this has to go to the Senate and Mitch
McConnell runs the Senate Mitch
McConnell went off this morning
specifically because Nancy Pelosi and
the Democrats have decided upon a
stratagem what exactly is their
stratagem their stratagem get ready for
it their strategy is that if President
if if they do not get the procedures
that they like from Mitch McConnell they
may withhold the impeachment articles so
they won't allow a Senate trial they'll
just hold it and won't send it over to
the Senate and offended by the way gets
to decide its own procedures the same
way the house gets to decide its
procedures Nancy Pelosi
she actually said this morning that they
may not convey and they may not convey
the articles of impeachment to the
Senate we have that clip so Pelosi is is
she announced this this is actually late
last night maybe we won't convey it
maybe we'll just sit here until we get
the impeachment procedures that we want
which is basically like that scene from
Blazing Saddles where the black sheriff
in an attempt to avoid his own lynching
puts a gun to his own head and threatens
the townspeople that he's gonna shoot
himself like this is the Democrats going
it's the Democrats saying if you know if
you don't give me what I want I'm gonna
commit suicide if you do not change your
procedures on impeachment we just won't
send you impeachment how about that how
about that and then he won't and then
he'll be he won't be
and then you'll and then here's Nancy
Pelosi again this is from Intel's last
night she's wearing her Palpatine her
Palpatine Emperor absolute power robe
here she goes well again we all decide
of what that dynamic is but we hope that
that the
resolution of all that process will be
soon in the center oh well she's not
going to it we'll see we won't appoint
impeachment managers until after the
Senate does what we want so Mitch
McConnell gets up on the floor of the
Senate this morning he's like what are
you are you joking
are you joking are you looking at me
cocaine Mitch you're looking at me a
turtle who deals actual crack cocaine
and you're telling me that you're going
to play with me does this look like the
face of a man you play with says Mitch
McConnell here it goes speaker Pelosi's
house just gave into a temptation that
every other house in our history has
managed to reserve they impeach a
president and they do not even allege
has committed an actual crime known to
our laws and then McConnell goes on he's
like and so your plan is to your plan is
to threaten me by not allowing me to
hold a trial on the impeachment articles
you are so confident of so you're your
pitch is if Trump isn't impeached like
Chris Matthews says then he'll just
he'll do anything to win no Jake I'll
call the Chinese he'll have them buzz
over voters in Iowa and and so your plan
is to not submit your articles of
impeachment to the only body capable of
removing President Trump from office and
to threaten the Republicans with this
looking petty and idiotic in the process
that's your plan that is your strategy
how do they think this is gonna play do
they think the American people gonna be
like well you know she's totally right I
guess that I guess that we can't have a
Senate trial until Mitch McConnell does
it the way Nancy Pelosi wants or is it
gonna be like listen we already are not
super fond of this you want to drag this
out by not even just submitting it so we
can get it over with you're the ones who
rush this thing forward in like two
months with no evidence sufficient to
support a criminal indictment this is
this is your strategy and not only is
this their idiot strategy they're
trotting out their best and brightest to
defend this ridiculous idiot strategy
they're trotting out Kamala Harris in
the Senate so I don't know if you got a
functional brain I do not know how the
person you choose to be the face of we
need fair procedures is the senator
who tried to suggest that justice
Cavanaugh is guilty of a bevy of rapes
for which there was no evidence
that's what Kamala Harris did she
trotted in like Michael a vanadis faked
victims or at least evidence free
victims and she started like telling
their stories in the middle of a Senate
hearing to try and thwart justice
Cavanaugh's appointment to the Supreme
Court commonly Harris is a joke so what
is the New York Times do they going to
get her to write an editorial on this
will McConnell let the Senate hold a
fair impeachment trial yes tell me more
about fair due process standards Kamala
Harris I mean that is when you're not
jailing mothers for truancy I mean tell
me more mistress of Justice when you're
not suggesting that everyone you just
like ought to be thrown in jail I
couldn't have found a worse face for
this particular thing a worse front for
this particular thing according to
common law Harris as a former prosecutor
I understand the importance of holding
powerful people accountable like true
and mothers and sending them to prison I
know that every trial requires fairness
and truth just like in the Justice
Cavanagh hearings where we didn't do
justice and we didn't do truth and we
just vomited out a bunch of allegations
with no evidence in order to smear a
dude because we didn't like his
perspective on Roe versus Wade commonly
Harris I mean what I don't know if the
New York like do they have a mirror over
at the New York Times do they have any
sense of self-awareness over at the New
York Times this is it's so amazing like
every time there is a story about a bad
foreign policy and it's incident for the
Trump administration supposedly they
trot out like Susan Rice to talk about
honesty
a person who lied to the American public
repeatedly about Benghazi and then when
there's a problem in the DOJ they try to
Eric Holder who called himself Barack
Obama's wingman to talk about honesty in
the DOJ and now they're trying to talk
about fair hearings on the Senate side
and they try not Kamala Harris the least
fair person in the Senate it's unreal
the lack of self-awareness is just
shocking Kamala Harris rights having
worked my whole life serving the people
I know that any trial that abandons the
pursuit of truth cannot be considered
just or fair justice Kavanagh 1000 times
justice Kavanagh she says but the Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell appears
more interested in covering up the
president's misconduct than in pursuing
truth and fairness he is already trying
to limit the impeachment trial by
preventing what
from testifying his alban announced a
verdict in doing so he showed the
american people he has no intention of
honoring his oath III feel like I'm
Pamela Harris who's already suggested
that she backs impeachment maybe she
should recuse maybe Elizabeth Warren
should recuse in fact maybe all the
Democrats should recuse since a huge
majority of them have already said
something about the impeachment
she said kumla Harris says let's be
clear mr. McConnell doesn't want to send
a trial he wants a Senate cover-up well
um it seems that Nancy Pelosi doesn't
want to send a trial either since she's
not actually just sending it see they
can make these same complaints after
McConnell does it this is this is the
part where you notice that the Democrats
have nothing because they can complain
the same way Republicans did when House
Democrats were shuffling through
incredibly narrow rules of order on the
impeachment side the Republicans
complain about it Democrats could do the
same thing they could say listen we did
the process that Republicans were unfair
Trump got off that's cuz they're unfair
instead they're like we're not even
gonna submit this thing we're not gonna
submit it cuz if we submit it then it
won't go our way and it might turn out
that our charges are extremely weak
ridiculous ridiculous Harris has a rep
Adam Schiff has a rep could you put
forward worse representatives of the we
are impartial truth seekers sure sure
you are okay time for a quick thing I
like and then a quick thing that I hate
so things that I like today so there is
a great video that was going around from
Northwestern University of a special
Olympian named Stefan Zita singing the
national anthem before a northwestern I
believes in Northwestern baseball game
and it's just it's just wonderful it's
it's pretty great here is it
[Music]
[Applause]
that's good stuff America is still
pretty great country even if our
politics is broken stupid and backwards
it's just as ridiculous other things
that are good so today a good thing from
the Trump administration US ambassador
Grinnell over in Germany rich Rick
Grinnell who's been just put upon by the
left date they hate Rick Grinnell
because he happens to be a gay man
serving in the Trump administration
Germany at at in cooperation with
Grinnell Germany ban Hezbollah it's in
its entirety they called it a terrorist
group which is a very important thing
because Hezbollah currently runs Lebanon
it's about to start a war with Israel
that will happen inside the next two to
three years it will be very ugly it'll
be very bloody this is what Hezbollah
does having Germany at least on the
right side of that battle is a big win
for the Trump administration and a win
for Western civilization the fact that
so many members of the EU continue to do
business with terrorist groups speaks to
their lack of moral rectitude and this
is why whenever people say why don't we
listen to what the Europeans have to say
yeah when they start actually treating
terrorism seriously in the Middle East
then I'll start listening to their
morale preening cuz I'm not I'm not
feeling it okay time for a quick thing
that I hate so Michelle wolf was so bad
at Comedy Inc that she lost her job on
Netflix which is nearly impossible to do
I mean Netflix doesn't even release
viewership statistics and Netflix had
hired her because they wanted they
didn't have enough left wingers they
needed somebody who was so wildly to the
left that they could then brag about how
wildly to the left she was well she did
a comedy routine the other night that
really does speak to the difference in
tone about abortion that has occurred on
the left so used to be every abortion is
a tragedy every abortions but they're
necessary in some circumstances and we
can't make that very hard judgment for a
woman it's a bad argument but at least
it's an emotionally appealing argument
and then you get to Michelle wolf this
is not just a bad argument it is not
even an emotionally appealing argument
it's actually it's actually just for
being extraordinarily evil I mean what
you're about to hear it does sound like
a Nazi eugenic celebration of the
killing of the unborn is what you're
about here and this was cheered by an
audience when I mean this is this is
hideous hideous stuff here's Michelle
wolf being both unfunny and also an
awful human being and we don't talk
about abortion in a real way we talk
about it in a very legislate
wait but not in a real way so I think a
lot of women have a lot of apprehension
surrounding it
you know we talked about so negatively
that you feel like you should have this
sense of shame after you get an abortion
well you can feel any way you want
after you get an abortion get one see
how you feel you know my abortion made
me feel very powerful you know people
say you can't play God
[Applause]
morgan freeman um yeah so that's um
that's a person being an evil person I
mean that is and that is M that that's
last Palpatine reference to the show I
promise that is Emperor Palpatine
absolute power okay
and there goes miss Windu but the fact
is that when you have people who are
openly cheering the fact I mean what
made her feel like God there
I mean analyze it for just a second what
made her feel so powerful so you don't
think she's lying I think she's being
honest about how she felt I think she
probably walked out of the abortion
clinic feeling very powerful because she
had gotten to define life on her own
terms which is not only playing God it's
also playing Satan I mean that is about
as evil as it gets I felt like I was
playing God when I took this human life
and I killed it for my own convenience
or for any other purpose because I felt
like defining it that way and thus I got
to end it and this is the same lady who
once suggested that that an abortion
isn't killing a human life it's just
preventing it it's like a DeLorean she
she actually made this comparison she
said it's like back to the future and
the DeLorean preventing inactivity in
the past yeah except for the fact that
it's already human life you want to
prevent the the formation of that human
life in the first place in the vast
majority of cases we're not talking
about rape we're talking about a
consensual sexual activity and pretty
easy way to prevent pregnancy birth
control does exist and or not having sex
does exist but in any case Michelle wolf
championing the abortion I mean this is
a shift in the language in the tone and
the tenor of the left and then you
wonder why evangelical Christians
support President Trump you don't have
to like President in Trump's treatment
of women you don't have to like the fact
that he says nasty things about people
enough to like a lot of things about the
dude but if the alternative is a
Democratic Party that thinks that that
is funny a Democratic Party and an
entire political wing of the United
States that cheers and laughs when a
human being says about the killing of an
unborn human being that that killing
made her feel powerful like God like
that's you I will vote for pretty much
anything before I vote for anybody who
laughs at that joke I mean that like
really I'll vote for pretty much and
evangelical Christians feel the same see
what the left wants to do is say you
have no moral standards if you vote for
President Trump because President Trump
is a bad man who's done bad things okay
well then what does it make you to vote
for people who want abortion on demand
all the way up to points of birth and
who refused to even acknowledge the
humanity of a baby five seconds before
it comes through a mother's vaginal
canal you're gonna have to explain that
one to me which is more immoral voting
for president who has allegedly sexually
harassed women or voting for somebody
who has pledged to make abortion on
demand not only legal across the country
but celebrated in our culture which
seems worse in terms of politics I'm not
talking about who you'd rather have
babysit your kid I'm not talking about
who you'd rather go to dinner with I'm
talking about the fundamental principles
at stake when you talk about partisan
politics in an environment like this an
environment that's polarized this is why
unless the Democrats were willing to
push forward an impeachment that was
actually supportable by facts unless
they're willing to push forward an
impeachment that was so overwhelming in
its in its criminal standards of proof
this was going nowhere from the outset
because if you think that anyone is
gonna go along with the Michelle wolf
wing simply because President Trump
doesn't know how to talk on phone calls
and says dumb crap a lot you are
thinking about this thing all wrong
you're thinking about it all wrong yeah
I said in 2016 that the election was not
a binary choice that you could choose to
abstain and what I meant by that was
that you could say neither of these
candidates meets my preferences that you
could back out of the fight and you
could basically say listen I don't know
which timeline is going to take
precedence here but it's important that
we least signal that we don't like any
of the candidates that are on the table
because if you never say no then you're
never going to get to a candidate where
you say yes but now we live in a new
reality okay the new reality was created
by the 2016 election in part but 2016
was also a recognition of an underlying
reality that a lot of people in politics
just didn't want to accept that our
politics are fundamentally broken and
that there are two separate visions of
the country that are increasingly
divergent and if you're going if the
question is vote Bernie Sanders or vote
Elizabeth Warren who has pledged to wear
a Planned Parenthood scarf
her inauguration or vote for President
Trump that decision is increasingly easy
and Democrats have made it increasingly
easy how the death of comedy by the way
is another adjunct to this according to
the critics Michelle wolf is incredibly
funny but louis c.k in the aftermath of
the allegations against him is no longer
funny these are the same people who
suggest that Hannah Gadsby as a true
comedienne because she has destroyed the
meaning of comedy is there anything that
the left isn't destroying at this point
that's not to say that the right is
hesitate is scot-free when it comes to
the destruction of American standards it
isn't but I don't see a lot of people on
the right saying that it felt good to
play God well they were aborting a baby
that's hideous stuff all right we'll be
back here later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise we
will see you here tomorrow I mention
Pierrot this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director pavel white house key
edited by adam sai events audio is mixed
by Mike Romina hair and makeup is by
Jess well alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin hosted
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clavin
[Music]